Huyện trường vở vụ của mấy bài vận tại quan sự gặp sự cố và giới xuống đại lộ,
khiến ít nhất mấy lâm người thiệt mạng tại Bolivia.
Sự việc sĩnh giá tối hemi bài tháng 2 và tại cơ tự của đáng 4,8 mời của không quân Bolivia,
tất cảnh từ sang ta Cruz, tới sinh vài thành phố Ananto.
Theo buộc không lất này, mấy bài gặp nạn khi đăng vận chuyển số tiền giấy người ín,
chưa gió số lợp để mình ăn hạn chúi hơn.
Huy hạ cánh, mấy bài đại trời khỏi đường bằng và đâm ra khu vực đồng lúc,
khiến ít nhất mấy lâm người thiệt mạng, và mình người khác bị thương,
nhiều phung tiện khác cũng bị hư hạ nhìn chào.
Lực lượng của hoa được điều đặc lập tức đến hiện trường giấc át đám trái,
chính quyền đã thạm thời đống cửa xin bài khu vụ tế Ananto,
và điều trạng của nhân vụ việc.